you mentioned Tucker what do you think
about Tucker getting fired from Fox
um you're a media person that works
independently yes
uh Tucker was a media person who doesn't
work independently right
uh yeah what do you what do you think
about that particular situation is it
representative of some big shift that's
happening in mainstream media
what would the ship be uh basically
mainstream media freaking out because
the funding is getting less and less and
less and less and there's going to give
more power to individual
commentators basically Tucker Carlson
just starting a podcast
so the YouTube channel I think that's
what he should do I think that's the
most profitable path rather than maybe
going to work for Newsmax or whatever
the case may be but the firing
fundamentally was not a politically
oriented firing that suggests Fox News
is changing its tune politically in any
way there's no evidence of that
whatsoever
um Tucker Carlson basically became a
legal problem for Fox News there's
really Four Points to it one is the 787
and a half million dollar settlement
with Dominion partially was because of
the
um claims that went out on Tucker
Carlson's program so to some degree
Tucker's program was a prominent uh node
of the problematic claims that became
the subject of the lawsuit that's number
one number two smartmatic which is
another voting Machine Company still has
a similarly sized lawsuit against Fox
News based on the exact same sorts of
claims it may cost Fox News again so
this is now two problems that Tucker's a
big contributor to number three former
Tucker staffer has brought a lawsuit and
I don't remember the exact claims but I
know that there are claims of different
types of discrimination it seems like it
has legs and that may be a third payout
related to Tucker Carlson and based on
the 60 Minutes piece from a few weeks
ago Ray Epps saying Tucker ruined his
life by fomenting conspiracies about him
around January 6th that's ripe for
another lawsuit so to me
Tucker's firing was a risk mitigation
strategy uh of many that will be
employed as as these lawsuits come
forward there's no evidence that it's
because
Fox didn't like and what we mean by that
who are we talking about Rupert Murdoch
doesn't like or the pre I don't know but
I don't have any reason to believe it's
because Tucker's ideas were no longer
welcome on Fox certainly the audience
liked them so interesting it's not about
it's not even about the ratings
it's about just the the legal costs
Fox is interesting the ratings question
is interesting because Fox unlike most
other or every other cable news channel
they negotiate a fee from every cable
subscriber if you have Fox News as a
channel even if you don't watch it Fox
gets a little bit of money they are
dramatically less dependent on ad
Revenue than CNN and MSNBC so the
ratings question is an interesting one
but Fox's position is different on that